I did a segment several days ago I think
it was a daily cancellation where I
talked about asexuals and in particular
I was responding to a profile of an
asexual in the New York Times The
Washington Post or one of these Outlets
they're all the same and they told us
about an asexual person and they even
introduced us to the asexual stuffed
animals
and uh and they gave us the names of the
stuffed animals too
um and that's the kind of thing
tailor-made for the daily cancellation I
mean when a mainstream Outlet puts
something like that out there I can only
assume that they have made it for the
daily that's that's it's just how could
I not include it in the daily
cancellation segment
um but that segment apparently I guess
has gone viral on Tick Tock and it's led
to a whole bunch of rebuttal and
reaction videos from the asexual
Community you're very upset about what I
said about asexuals and also the plushy
Enthusiast Community said as well so uh
here's one of those videos
so I heard that all you have to do to
piss off Matt Walsh is to be asexual and
have plushies
so I'm asexual let's meet my pleasures
it's Lotus she her
foreign
this is Kaden uh she they
pomp him
Meadow see them
Priscilla she her
this is I'm doing this right blushes
than I thought
okay good well so you see I mean clearly
everything I said about you know
asexuals maybe having some issues well
obviously I'm wrong I've been I've been
proven totally wrong
listen
uh
the point I made there that I will
reiterate is that you know
if you are defining yourself your your
perceived inability to develop romantic
attractions to other people
um that's not an identity
to be embraced
okay it's it's that's the absence of
something that is your your inability to
experience one of the is something
that's that's Central to The Human
Condition You know the ability to to
experience love and romantic attraction
it's part of what makes us human beings
and so if you perceive yourself to be
unable to do that it's not that's not
your identity now this this this
emptiness this absence is not an
identity
and it's bad enough when people
claim an identity
you know find their identity entirely in
their sexual attractions that's bad
enough because our identity should not
be completely tied up in our sexual
proclivities and attractions that
shouldn't be our whole identity our
whole personality but to make your whole
identity in your whole personality the
lack of that
is even worse
and it's also not something that you
need to just accept
that's part of the problem with making
an identity put it on the flag you know
you have your own acronym in the in the
uh in the LGBT thing you have your own
letter in the acronym uh when you do
that you've just you've you've embraced
and accepted this thing that you don't
need to
because
um there there's obviously some other
issues that are going on that you need
to address
and if you address that then you may
discover that actually although you
perceive yourself to be unable to
develop romantic attractions and to have
that kind of bond with another human
being you perceive that yourself to be
unable to do that you actually are able
to do it but you have to go and get the
help that you need to be able to
experience that aspect of being a human
so I think it's it's a rather
encouraging and uplifting message from
me at least it's as of lifting and
encouraging as it gets okay it's the
best you're gonna get from me
[Music]
[Applause]